hey boys and girls this is tim ferriss
and i would like to cover psychedelics
101 a few recommended resources
first for context i've spent the last 10
years heavily involved
with the scientific research as a
source of financing primarily for johns
hopkins
for imperial college in london for
research at the university of auckland
and the reason that i'm so involved with
supporting research
both into predominantly psilocybin but
also lsd
and mdma is that i believe psychedelic
compounds
hold the potential to treat treatment
resistant conditions that are very
poorly treated with current psychiatric
approaches and medications so that would
include chronic depression that would
include
chronic anxiety things like ocd
ptsd eating disorders it's a pretty long
list
most of them i would say are associated
with some degree of rigidity
or repetitive patterning and
they've changed my life certainly i'm a
case study in many respects
but i want that to be tested with
rigorous scientific research so that's
what i'm up to and i've dedicated
millions of dollars in many years to
this at this point
so let's start with books in the
category books there are a million books
about psychedelics certainly michael
pollins how to change your mind is
excellent if you want to read a teaser
of that
really the new yorker article that was
the precursor to that book the trip
treatment is a pretty short read and you
can also hear
michael pollan since he and i have had
multiple conversations on my podcast
including effectively a two-hour summary
of his book
and you can find those at 10. blog
outside of michael pollan
there are some lesser known books the
healing journey by claudio naranjo
is excellent and really talks about a
number of compounds but also combining
psychotherapeutic rappers some type of
preparation and guiding and integration
with the use of these powerful compounds
it's an outstanding
description of what can happen and what
can be done
with many of these compounds so the
healing journey by claudio naranjo
the next book i'll mention is the secret
chief which is about
leo zeph zff who was one of the best
known facilitators
and guides who conducted many many
informal empirical experiments with
many many subjects probably hundreds of
different subjects
and it's it's a really helpful window
into
what facilitation can look like
consciousness medicine
by friends suas borza b-o-u-r-z-a-t
is a newer book written by friends suas
and she
is an exceptionally experienced
facilitator who spent time with the
mazatec
indians in mexico in the state of oaxaca
and their area of expertise or areas of
expertise include
these philosophy mushrooms magic
mushrooms as they're known
which are so widely distributed now in
north america but they're really
introduced
through the mazatechs and other
indigenous peoples of that area
so francoise has a lot of experience not
only with the indigenous paths
but also with the western
psychotherapeutic models and she's very
very good at combining the two
she also has a lot of familiarity with
trauma work so i would suggest taking a
look at that
for documentaries if you want to watch
documentaries there's a lot of garbage
a few that i think are good include trip
of compassion which shows
actual session footage of mdma assisted
psychotherapy
transforming people who have complex and
treatment-resistant
ptsd post-traumatic stress disorder
whether that's from kidnapping
from bombings from any number
of different stressful events in life
that could be
inclusive of veterans victims of sexual
abuse and so on
so trip of compassion is an exceptional
movie it is low production value but
very
high impact and you just have to be
patient with it it is very intense also
i'll warn you in advance
from shock to awe covers the
healing paths of several veterans
tracing them from
opiate or i should say medication
prescription medication addiction
to use of psychedelics and the effects
that those have had on their lives
i should also say just as a quick side
note psychedelics are not a panacea they
involve very real risks
but they do have some very interesting
applications another film is
dost dos ed which
i'll leave at higher production value
and also a single primary female
protagonist
and this includes the use of iboga or
ibogaine
for opioid addiction specifically and
takes place in
british columbia and canada so those are
a few documentaries i'm sure there are
more coming they're also short video
series
by horizons which is a group best known
for its events
related to psychedelics but they've
produced some very very good
short films and videos that you can also
find on youtube
and elsewhere for researchers if you're
interested in digging into
the research or research if you prefer
you can certainly go to the johns
hopkins
center page i think it's just hopkins
psychedelic.com or dot org but if you
search johns hopkins psychedelic it will
pop right up
that is the first center for psychedelic
and consciousness research
in the united states a number of names
come to mind
include roland griffiths and matt
johnson but
the entire team there is exceptional and
they have published a lot
their studies have really been seminal
pieces of literature in
resurrecting psychedelics and creating
what people are calling the psychedelic
renaissance a lot of their work out of
johns hopkins
you have imperial college london robin
carhart harris david nutt and
others who are doing tremendous work
including some very image intensive
research with fmri i would encourage you
to take a look at
their studies there are as i mentioned
research centers or i should say
certainly serious serious research being
conducted also
at nyu new york university that includes
michael bogan shoots steve ross looking
at
psilocybin as found in so-called magic
mushrooms for alcohol use disorder
and other conditions so you can find
fantastic researchers actually now
jumping into the fray all over the u.s
there is an initiative at uc berkeley
now
and at many other institutions that are
really really
well respected for not just their work
in psychedelics but across the board
so from medical and scientific
perspective things have never been
more exciting so i'm i'm
very very thrilled to be involved with
all of that
there's certainly many thinkers many
people have written on these subjects
commented on these subjects i will say
when in doubt approach this subject area
with a high degree of skepticism
and an even higher degree of caution
you really want to measure twice and cut
once here i would not encourage
recreational use but if you have
a condition that may be well treated
that
is demonstrated in the literature to
respond well to these compounds
then it's worth doing some homework and
also
noting that most of them remain illegal
federally and otherwise
in the united states and many other
countries so i'm not
recommending that you use psychedelics
but it is a fascinating
area to study and really immerse
yourself in
if you want some of the the wackier
stuff that i find very interesting also
uh from some of the south american canon
or at least descriptions of things
in south america the wizard of the upper
amazon and singing to the plants
will give you a decent overview of what
the
animistic and sort of vegetalist
they would say vegetalismo
facets of the ayahuasca world
specifically look like
in the peruvian amazon and elsewhere in
the amazon
so with that should be plenty to start
with there's plenty more
of course you can find many podcasts on
these subjects and different compounds
on microdosing on ibogaine
specifically on my podcast the tim
ferriss show
at tim.blog forward slash podcast and
thanks for
listening
you